As the 2020 election cycle heats up, inevitably so will conversations among family, friends, and acquaintances on opposite ends of the political spectrum. The United States may be more politically polarized than ever, but our disagreements don't have to devolve into shouting matches and ideological one-upmanship. But how can you have a civil conversation about politics with someone who disagrees with you? Is it even worth it to try? For people who want to try to engage in meaningful dialogues with those who disagree with them. Psychologists have some practical advice to offer. Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association
随着2020年大选周期的升温，政治光谱对立的家人、朋友和熟人之间的对话也难免会随之升温。美国可能比以往任何时候都更加政治极化，但我们的分歧并不一定要演变成大喊大叫和意识形态上的争强好胜。但是，你如何能与一个与你意见不合的人就政治问题进行一场文明的对话呢？尝试一下真的值得吗？对于那些想要尝试与与自己意见不合的人进行有意义对话的人。心理学家有一些切实的建议。欢迎收听美国心理学会的旗舰播客《心理学畅谈》
that explores the connections between psychological science and everyday life. I'm Kim Mills. Our guest today is Dr. Tanya Israel, a professor in the Department of Counseling, Clinical, and School Psychology at the University of California, Santa Barbara. after years of leading workshops teaching people how to talk about their political differences, she has published a book, Beyond Your Bubble, How to Connect Across the Political Divide, with advice on how to initiate these conversations, keep your cool, and ultimately better understand each other. Welcome to speaking of psychology, Dr. Israel.
该播客探讨了心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。我是金·米尔斯（Kim Mills）。我们今天的嘉宾是加利福尼亚大学圣巴巴拉分校咨询、临床与学校心理学系的教授托尼亚·伊斯雷尔博士（Dr. Tanya Israel）。经过多年领导工作坊，教导人们如何谈论他们的政治分歧后，她出版了一本名为《超越你的气泡：如何跨越政治鸿沟进行连接》（Beyond Your Bubble, How to Connect Across the Political Divide）的书，其中包含关于如何发起这些对话、保持冷静以及最终更好地彼此理解的建议。欢迎来到《心理学畅谈》，伊斯雷尔博士。
Thank you so much, Kim. I'm delighted to be here. Let's start with a definition. You aim to teach people how to have what you call dialogue as opposed to discourse, diatribe, or debate. what are the differences among those terms and what is meaningful dialogue? So I always try to frame what this book is trying to help people do. And when I talk about dialogue, what I'm talking about is a conversation that takes place between two people who want to be in that dialogue. So sometimes people get concerned that just because they can do it, that that's a mandate
非常感谢你，金。我很高兴能来到这里。让我们从一个定义开始。你的目标是教人们如何进行你所谓的“对话”（dialogue），而不是“交流”（discourse）、“抨击”（diatribe）或“辩论”（debate）。这些术语之间有什么区别？什么是有意义的对话？因此，我总是试图界定这本书旨在帮助人们做什么。当我谈论“对话”时，我指的是两个都希望参与其中的人之间进行的对话。所以有时人们会担心，仅仅因为他们能做到这一点，这就是对他们的要求
for them to do it. And, you know, I want people to know that they have choices. So it's dialogue with a person who wants to do it face to face, not Facebook to Facebook. So really the idea is that this is a conversation that people are having either in person or it could be on Skype or Zoom or on the phone even, but not in writing and certainly not in social media. And with people who have differing perspectives and those differing perspectives don't have to be the most extreme differences. So that really frames what I want to help people do. And in terms of the difference between that and some of the other kinds of conversations people might have, diatribe or discourse or debate, this is not about trying to win an argument.
让他们去这么做。而且，你知道的，我希望人们知道他们是有选择的。所以，这是与一个想要进行对话的人面对面地交谈，而不是“脸书”对“脸书”（Facebook to Facebook）。因此，真正的理念是，这是一场人们当面进行的对话，也可以通过Skype、Zoom甚至电话进行，但绝不是以文字形式，当然也不是在社交媒体上。并且是与那些有着不同观点的人进行的，而这些不同的观点不必是最极端的差异。这才是真正界定了我想帮助人们做的事情。至于这与其他类型的人们可能会进行的对话（如抨击、交流或辩论）之间的区别，这并不是为了赢得争论。
This is people have a lot of different motivations for what brings them to, to dialogue, but this isn't just about people expressing their views and expressing their emotions. This is more often about people trying to build understanding or maintain relationships. It would be hard to think of a topic that is more polarizing right now than the upcoming presidential elections. There are some people who are hard-line, dyed in the wool pro-Trumpers, and others who would vote for a can of tomato soup rather than support the incumbent president? Is it possible for people on those two extremes to have a real dialogue? And to what end, since the chances of changing either side's mind is probably nil?
人们出于许多不同的动机来到对话中，但这不仅仅是人们表达他们的观点和情绪。这更通常是为了建立理解或维护关系。很难想象现在有什么话题比即将到来了总统大选更具两极分化。有些人是强硬的、根深蒂固的特朗普支持者，而另一些人宁愿投票给一罐番茄汤，也不愿支持现任总统？处于这两个极端的群体之间，有可能进行真正的对话吗？其最终目的又是什么呢？因为改变任何一方想法的可能性几乎为零？
So that's a great question. And I hear that a lot. So why are we doing this at all? Is this even possible? And one of the things that I hear from people is that they just cannot understand how somebody else could think as they do or vote as they do. And so what I always think is, well, if you can't understand and you have someone in front of you who could help you to understand, wouldn't you want to take advantage of that? Wouldn't you want to try to find out from that person what you're really having trouble grasping? So that can be one of the goals in itself, just to try to understand. Also, that lack of understanding can cause a lot of distress for people. People are very disturbed by the upcoming election, and over the last four years, people have been really disturbed by the stress of the political divide.
这是一个很好的问题。我经常听到这个问题。那么，我们为什么还要做这件事呢？这真的可能吗？我从人们那里听到的一点是，他们根本不明白为什么别人会像他们那样思考或像他们那样投票。所以我总是想，好吧，如果你无法理解，而你面前又有人能帮你理解，难道你不想利用这一点吗？难道你不想从那个人那里找出你真正难以理解的地方吗？所以这本身就可以成为目标之一，仅仅是试图去理解。此外，缺乏理解会给人们带来很多痛苦。人们对即将到来的大选感到非常不安，在过去的四年里，人们一直对政治分裂带来的压力感到非常不安。
And we know that. You know, APA has research that shows that people's stress around politics has increased. And so hopefully this is something that can help people to reduce their stress, help to promote understanding. And I also hear a lot from people who want to maintain relationships with people who are in their lives, family members, co-workers, friends from high school, other parents at their children's school. And they're not sure how to do that. And so this can be very helpful in that. And then it can also be helpful in terms of talking about and trying to resolve some of these political issues. So if we do have dialogue, that could help to move.
我们都知道这一点。你知道的，美国心理学会（APA）的研究表明，人们对政治的压力增加了。所以希望这能帮助人们减轻压力，促进理解。我经常听到人们想要维持他们生活中的人际关系，包括家庭成员、同事、高中朋友、孩子学校的其他家长。他们不确定该怎么做。这在方面可以非常有用。此外，它还有助于讨论和试图解决其中一些政治问题。因此，如果我们确实进行了对话，这可能有助于推动
us toward identifying common ground and maybe even working together on some of these issues. You've written in your book that before people engage in meaningful dialogue, they need to understand their own motivations and what they want to accomplish. Sometimes people may have more than one motivation or even motivations that conflict with one another. Why is it important to sort out your goals before you even try to have these conversations? At first I thought, oh, well, if I just help people to identify what their motivations are and have them keep that in mind, then they'll really want to learn the skills and implement the skills that will help them to have dialogue. It turns out it's a little bit more complex than that because sometimes people do have a motivation
我们走向寻找共同点，甚至可能在其中一些问题上进行合作。你在书中写过，在人们进行有意义的对话之前，他们需要了解自己的动机以及他们想要实现什么。有时人们可能不止一种动机，甚至会有彼此冲突的动机。为什么在尝试进行这些对话之前理清你的目标很重要？起初我想，哦，好吧，如果我只是帮助人们明确他们的动机，并让他们牢记这一点，那么他们就会真正想要学习技能并实施这些技能，从而帮助他们进行对话。事实证明，这比这稍微复杂一些，因为有时人们确实有这样一种动机
where they want to maintain a relationship with a family member. But they also might have a motivation to want to feel validated in their own views or to openly express what their experiences and their values are. So one of the things that's helpful about knowing what your motivations are is that these conversations can be challenging. And sometimes you need something that's going to help you to want to persist past the discomfort and the emotions that come up around the conversations. You say that for successful dialogue to happen across political lines, we need to do two things.
他们想要维持与家庭成员的关系。但他们也可能有一种动机，希望自己的观点得到验证，或者公开表达他们的经历和价值观是什么。因此，了解你的动机的好处之一是，这些对话可能具有挑战性。有时你需要一些东西来帮助你坚持下去，克服对话中带来的不适和情绪。你说，为了跨越政治分歧进行成功的对话，我们需要做两件事。
try to understand your conversation partner and then help that person feel safe and understood and that the way you do this is through active listening. What is active listening? How do you become an active listener? One of the things that I really wanted to bring forth in this book is something I've been teaching for years in my helping skills class, which is active listening. And this is something that we have loads of research on in psychology about the benefits of active listening and what it looks like. So active listening, Stephen Covey in Seven Habits of Highly Effective People, describes this as listening to understand instead of listening to respond. So when somebody's talking, rather than thinking about what's the thing that you're going to say
试图理解你的对话伙伴，然后帮助那个人感到安全和被理解，而你做到这一点的方式是通过积极倾听。什么是积极倾听？你如何成为一个积极的倾听者？我在这本书中真正想要表达的事情之一，是我多年来一直在我的“帮助技能”课上教授的内容，即积极倾听。这是我们在心理学中拥有大量研究的内容，关于积极倾听的好处以及它的表现形式。因此，积极倾听，史蒂芬·柯维（Stephen Covey）在《高效能人士的七个习惯》（Seven Habits of Highly Effective People）中将其描述为：为了理解而听，而不是为了回应而听。所以当有人在说话时，与其去想你要说的是什么
to contrast with what they're saying, it's giving them space to actually express what they're going to say, and then responding by demonstrating that you understand by giving a reflection that summarizes what they've just said. And that can help people to feel more comfortable sharing more if they feel like you've heard them. And it can also help people to clarify their views. Maybe you reflect back to them something. You say, no, that's not exactly what I'm thinking. And it gives a chance to go into more depth with things. And then the other component is when you do want to ask questions, asking open-ended questions, so not just yes or no questions, but questions that really encourage elaboration. And also questions that aren't just trying to trap somebody or aren't just
来反驳他们所说的话，不如给他们空间去真正表达他们要说的话，然后通过给出总结他们刚刚所说内容的反馈来表明你理解了，从而作出回应。如果他们觉得你听进去了，这可以帮助人们感到更舒适，从而分享更多。这也可以帮助人们澄清他们的观点。也许你向他们反省了某些内容。你说，不，这不完全是我所想的。这提供了一个更深入探讨问题的机会。另一个组成部分是，当你确实想提问时，要提出开放式问题，而不仅仅是“是”或“否”的问题，而是真正鼓励详细阐述的问题。还有那些不仅仅是为了给某人设套或仅仅是
statements or gotchas like, you know, don't you think this? That's not really a question. So questions that promote understanding. That sounds like a really great technique and probably something that we should all do more regularly, but how do you get yourself to employ it when you're listening to somebody who says something that you really find just repugnant, offensive, or just wrong? How do you keep you cool? I have found that even before the skills, one of the underlying stances that we need to have is one of curiosity. It's important that we really do want to know, that we really do want to understand. And if you really want to understand and you hear somebody say something, you think, my gosh, that is just ridiculous and wrongheaded, well, you can tell someone that that's ridiculous and wrongheaded, but that doesn't actually get you any closer to understanding. But saying to somebody, oh, I would love to hear a little bit more about how you came to that view, that can help you to understand more where they're coming from.
陈述或“抓把柄”的问题，比如“难道你不这么认为吗？”那其实并不是一个真正的问题。因此，要提出能够促进理解的问题。这听起来是一个非常棒的技术，可能也是我们所有人都应该更经常去做的事情，但是当你听一个说了你觉得非常令人反感、具有攻击性或根本就是错误的话的人说话时，你如何让自己去运用它呢？你如何保持冷静？我发现，甚至在技能之前，我们需要具备的根本立场之一就是好奇心。重要的是，我们确实想要去了解，我们确实想要去理解。如果你真的想要去理解，当你听到有人说出某种话时，你会想，天哪，这简直是荒谬且思想错误的，好吧，你可以告诉某人这是荒谬且思想错误的，但这实际上并不能让你更接近理解。但是对某人说，哦，我很想多听听你是如何持有那种观点的，这可以帮助你更多地理解他们的立场。
Do you have to just listen in these cases? When do you get to talk? how do you know it's your turn to talk and how do you do so in a way that doesn't alienate the conversation partner? Maybe you just talked about that a little bit. Well, no, I think that's a great question. Everybody always wants to know, when do I get to talk? Do I really just have to spend all my time listening? When I started doing these workshops, the first half of the workshop is all about listening because that's such a foundational skill for building that connection that will allow you to be able to express your views more. and have the other person really hear them.
在这些情况下，你必须只是听吗？你什么时候才能说话？你如何知道轮到你说话了，你又该如何以一种不会疏远对话伙伴的方式说话？也许你刚才已经讲了一点点。嗯，不，我认为这是一个很好的问题。每个人总是想知道，我什么时候能说话？难道我真的只能把所有时间都花在倾听上吗？当我开始做这些工作坊时，工作坊的前半部分全是关于倾听的，因为这是建立联系的基础技能，有了这种联系，你才能更好地表达你的观点。
And I give some guidance about that in the book, sort of when to do that. But the other crucial thing about when you talk is how do you talk and how do you share your views in a way that it's likely to be most effective. And one of the things that we might find is that when we're talking with people who agree with us, we can give some kind of shorthand views that can, you know, give some kind of shorthand views that can fit on a bumper sticker and we've got slogans and we've got statistics and we can go, yeah, that's right. And we get lots of encouragement from other people and that feels really great.
并且让另一个人真正听到它们。我在书中对此提供了一些指导，也就是什么时候去做。但关于你何时说话的另一个关键问题是，你如何说话，以及你如何以最有可能最有效的方式分享你的观点。我们可能会发现的一点是，当我们与那些同意我们观点的人交谈时，我们可以给出某种速记式的观点，可以，你知道的，给出一些可以贴在汽车保险杠贴纸上的速记式观点，我们有口号，我们有统计数据，我们可以说，是的，那是对的。我们从其他人那里得到了很多鼓励，这感觉真的很棒。
If we then turn around and try to talk to somebody who is on another side of an issue and use those same statistics and slogans and the same kind of energy around that, it's not likely to help us to meet our goals. So some of the things that we might do instead are to tell our story about how we came to our views. We often think that we came to our views because of all of those statistics and, you know, logical things. But there's lots of research in the field of psychology that shows that that's not typically how we form our views. We're more likely to pay attention to statistics that are already aligned with our values. So talking more about our values and how we came to that can be a much more accessible way to share with somebody what our thoughts are on something. In some of these cases, are you really just sort of squelching what you really think in order to give the other person room? Because it sounds like you're talking about some people who really just want to confirm the biases that they already have.
如果我们随后转身试图与处于问题另一方的人交谈，并使用相同的统计数据和口号以及围绕该问题的同一种能量，这不太可能帮助我们实现我们的目标。因此，我们可以采取的一些替代做法是，讲述我们是如何得出这些观点的故事。我们经常认为我们得出这些观点是因为所有那些统计数据以及，你知道的，符合逻辑的事情。但是心理学领域有大量研究表明，这通常不是我们形成观点的方式。我们更有可能注意到那些已经符合我们价值观的统计数据。因此，更多地谈论我们的价值观以及我们是如何得出这一结论的，可以是一种更容易让人接受的方式，向某人分享我们对某事的想法。在其中一些情况下，你是否真的只是在压抑你真正的想法，以便给对方留出空间？因为听起来你谈到的一些人只是想证实他们已经持有的偏见。
And so you accept the data that confirm what you think you know. and I may be having a conversation with you and feel like, yeah, but you know, you're really not paying attention to the good statistics over here. This is a science and that's fake news and you're just wrong. I know that's so frustrating, isn't it? It really is. And everybody is experiencing that. Well, it turns out that we are all just trying to confirm our biases. And the field of psychology has so much to offer here because,
所以你接受那些证实你自以为知道的事物的数据；而我可能在跟你对话时觉得，是的，但是你知道的，你真的没有关注这边好的统计数据。这是一门科学，那是假新闻，你就是错的。我知道这太令人沮丧了，不是吗？确实如此。每个人都在经历这一点。好吧，事实证明，我们所有人其实都只是在试图证实我们的偏见。心理学领域在这里能提供很多东西，因为
that will say that over and over and over again. And we only believe that that's true about the other people. You know, we think that we're making these very, you know, logical, well-thought-out decisions and only paying attention to, you know, the good research and therefore the other people must be wrong. It turns out that human beings have these tendencies. And even knowing that doesn't help us to know what to do about it. That's what I try to offer in the book is some ideas about how do you actually. then have a conversation with somebody who's paying attention to very different kinds of
它会一遍又一遍、反反复复地指出这一点。而我们只认为这在其他人身上是真的。你知道的，我们认为我们正在做出这些非常、你知道的，符合逻辑的、深思熟虑的决定，并且只关注，你知道的，好的研究，因此其他人一定是错的。事实证明，人类确实有这些倾向。甚至连知道这一点也无济于事，无法帮我们知道该对此做些什么。这就是我试图在书中提供的，关于你实际上该如何去做的一些想法。然后与一个正在关注截然不同事物的人进行对话
things. And there were areas of psychology research that I already knew a lot about going into writing this book, but there were some that were newer to me. And one of the things I learned a lot about was the way that we distort our perceptions of people who we perceive as being on the other side. And this is what some of it's about is really thinking that they are illogical, that they are mean-spirited, that we have all kinds of ideas about the other side. Well, they have those same ideas about us, it turns out. And there are actually some strategies that can help us to take somebody else's perspective and see things from their view. And that can help us move toward what we call intellectual humility, which is another area that I learned more about in developing this book.
事物。心理学研究中有一些领域是我在写这本书之前就已经了解很多的，但也有一些对我来说比较新。我了解得很多的一个事情是，我们扭曲对那些被我们视为在对立面的人的看法的方式。这就是其中一部分内容，真正认为他们是不逻辑的，他们是刻薄的，我们对对立面有各种各样的看法。好吧，事实证明，他们对我们也有同样的看法。实际上有一些策略可以帮助我们采纳别人的视角，从他们的角度看问题。这可以帮助我们走向我们所说的“理智的谦逊”（intellectual humility），这是我在撰写这本书的过程中学到的另一个领域。
And I think of that as how to be righteous without being self-righteous. Is it harder or easier to have these kinds of conversations with family or close friends versus people who are just acquaintances or even strangers? It seems like there'd be more emotionally at stake when we talk to people who are close to us, but sometimes those are the people where we act out the most in negative ways. Sure. Well, I think it's easier to avoid these conversations with people who aren't close to us. You know, we can have an interaction with somebody or witness something.
我认为这就如同如何在不自以为是的情况下做到正直。与家人或密友进行这类对话，是比与熟人甚至陌生人进行更容易还是更难？似乎当我们与亲近的人交谈时，利益相关的感情更多，但有时这些人反而是我们以最消极的方式表现出情绪的人。当然。嗯，我认为避免与不亲密的人进行这些对话更容易。你知道的，我们可以与某人进行互动，或者目睹某些事情。
There's a lot going on right now around mask wearing. And people see what other people are doing or not doing. and, you know, are, and I hear people say, you know, well, I don't know if I should go and tell that person that what they're doing is wrong or if I should confront them. And it's interesting how we usually think about that that interaction would have to be conflictual in that way, that we couldn't go and say, hey, I notice, you know, that you're not wearing a mask. And I'm, I'm wondering how you're making your decision about that, you know. But it's usually easier just to not do that with somebody who we don't know. And so we might have more motivation to actually have those conversations with people who are already in our lives and who we want to keep in our lives. I'm going to ask you a question that maybe you don't have any research behind it, but I'd still like to run this past you.
现在关于戴口罩有很多讨论。人们看到其他人在做什么或不做什么。并且，你知道的，而且，我听到人们说，你知道的，嗯，我不知道我是否应该去告诉那个人他们做错了，或者我是否应该与他们对抗。有趣的是，我们通常认为这种互动必须是那种对抗性的，我们不能走过去说，嘿，我注意到，你知道的，你没戴口罩。而且我，我很想知道你是如何对此做出决定的，你知道的。但通常情况下，与一个我们不认识的人不做这种事会更容易。所以我们可能更有动力去与那些已经存在于我们的生活中并且我们希望留在我们生活中的人进行这些对话。我要问你一个问题，也许你没有任何研究支持，但我还是想跟你探讨一下。
How do you think America got to this place where people are so polarized and angry and self-righteous about their beliefs? I'm going to out myself as an older person. I grew up in the 50s and 60s when people would not dare to scream at each other in public or hurl the F-bomb at strangers. Do you have any theory about why we've stopped being civil to each other? Sure. I've got a couple of thoughts about that. I think that both media and social media have contributed to this. So one of the things in the media that we see, and, you know, in my lifetime also, we've shifted to this 24-hour news.
你认为美国是如何走到这一步的，人们对自己的信仰如此极化、愤怒和自以为是？我要暴露自己是个年长的人了。我在50和60年代长大，那时人们绝不敢在公众场合对彼此尖叫，或者对陌生人飙F脏话。你对我们为什么不再对彼此保持文明有什么理论吗？当然。对此我有几个想法。我认为媒体和社交媒体都对此负有责任。所以我们在媒体中看到的事情之一，而且，在我的一生中，我们也转向了这种24小时新闻。
cycle. And keeping people engaged in watching the news for 24 hours a day takes some doing. You've got to have something interesting for people to watch. And so drama is more interesting than not drama, apparently on TV. And so when we see these conversations across political lines on TV, typically they have set it up so that there's conflict. So there are people who are more extreme or who are spokespeople for the different sides. And we're missing there the full range of what people's views are. And so when people think about having a conversation with somebody on the other side, they're imagining these people who are the most extreme examples of those views,
循环。让人们连续24小时保持观看新闻的状态需要下一番功夫。你必须为人们提供一些有趣的东西来看。所以，戏剧性比不戏剧性更有趣，在电视上显然是这样的。因此，当我们在电视上看到跨政治阵线的这些对话时，通常他们会将之设置为存在冲突的。因此，会有更极端的人或者不同阵线的代言人。我们在那里错失了人们观点的全貌。因此，当人们考虑与对立面的人进行对话时，他们想象的是那些拥有这些观点最极端例子的人，
because that's what they've seen or heard in the media. So that's the media piece. The social media piece is that people are on social media more often sort of expressing their views out, and it's not about sort of an exchange back and forth. So that's one piece of it that we're not as skilled, I would say, at doing that back and forth because of social media. But the other piece about social media is that we're saying the same thing to everyone. And it's not as nuanced as if we're having some kinds of conversations with people who agree with us and some kinds of conversations with people who don't agree with us. And having the skill to be able to do both of those things is very useful in life.
因为那是他们在媒体上看到或听到的。所以这是媒体部分。社交媒体部分是人们更经常在社交媒体上表达他们的观点，而不是一种来回的交流。所以这是其中的一部分，由于社交媒体的原因，我可以说我们不太擅长进行这种来回的互动。但关于社交媒体的另一个部分是，我们对每个人说的都是同样的话。它不像我们与同意我们观点的人进行某种对话、以及与不同意我们观点的人进行某种对话那样具有细微差别。具备同时做到这两者的能力在生活中是非常有用的。
That kind of flexibility is beneficial in a lot of different. areas in our lives interpersonally. So that's one of the pieces. There's actually an interesting study that was done with people on Twitter where they had Republicans who they tweeted liberal tweets to these Republicans. And then they tweeted conservative tweets to the Democrats. Because, of course, we always think that, you know, if we just put out there the view that contrasts that we're going to share the right research and then they'll wake up and they'll see how wrong they are. Right. Right. That's what we think is going to happen. But it's actually the opposite that the more those participants paid attention to those views, the farther polarized they got. So these kind of, you know, back and forth things
这种灵活性在我们生活中人际交往的许多不同领域都是有益的。所以这是其中一部分。实际上有一项有趣的实验是在推特（Twitter）用户身上进行的，他们向这些共和党人推送了自由派的推文。然后他们向民主党人推送了保守派的推文。因为，当然，我们总是认为，你知道的，如果我们只是把对比鲜明的观点放出去，我们将分享正确的研究，然后他们就会醒悟并看到他们是多么错误。对。对。我们以为会发生这种情况。但实际情况恰恰相反，这些参与者对这些观点的关注度越高，他们的两极分化就越严重。所以这种，你知道的，来回的事情
that we're trying to do on social media, not only are they not helping to promote understanding, but they're pushing us farther apart. So you've said that your advice works best for face-to-face conversations. And as we've been talking, a lot of the conversations that people are having today about politics is happening online. Is it possible to use your techniques on Facebook or other social platforms? Or can you just not have any meaningful dialogue on, say, some kind of a comment wall? You know, I think that the most useful comment that you can make to somebody who expresses a view that's different from yours is to say, hey, I would love to understand more about where you're coming from. Can we set up a time to talk? So you just have to kind of make a separate
我们在社交媒体上试图做的事情，不仅无助于促进理解，反而把我们推得更远。所以你曾说过你的建议最适合面对面交流。正如我们一直在谈论的，人们今天关于政治的很多对话都是在线上进行的。是否有可能在脸书或其他社交平台上使用你的技术？或者你根本无法在诸如某种评论墙之类的东西上进行任何有意义的对话？你知道的，我认为你可以对一个表达了与你不同观点的人作出的最有用的评论是，嘿，我非常想更多地了解你的立场。我们可以约个时间聊聊吗？所以你只需腾出一个单独的
room where you can go and have the dialogue, but it's important to make it a one-on-one. It turns out that if we are trying to understand somebody, the more types of information we have in terms of input, the easier it is for us to understand them. So just seeing somebody commenting on social media doesn't give us a lot of information. But if we can hear the intonation of somebody's voice and even better if we can see their nonverbals, the more of those sources that we have, the easier it's going to be for us to have that understanding. So moving beyond your work, getting people to break out of their bubble, that's only one aspect of your work. A lot of your research has been on LGBTQ mental health, and I know you've
你可以去进行对话的空间，但把它变成一对一的交流是很重要的。事实证明，如果我们试图理解某人，我们在输入方面拥有的信息类型越多，我们就越容易理解他们。因此，仅仅看到某人在社交媒体上发表评论并不能给我们提供很多信息。但如果我们能听到某人说话的语调，如果能看到他们的非言语行为就更好了，我们拥有的这些来源越多，我们就越容易建立这种理解。因此，超越你的工作，让人们打破他们的泡沫，这只是你工作的一个方面。你的很多研究都关于LGBTQ心理健康，我知道你曾
done public outreach, including a very popular TED talk on bisexuality. How does this tie in with your whole social discourse work? That's a great question because I ended up writing this book not about the work that I've been doing for the last couple of decades on LGBT intervention research, but about a completely different topic. So the work that I've been doing on LGBTQ issues has really brought me into some difficult dialogues. And I've, you know, facilitated dialogue around religion and sexual orientation.
做过公众宣传，包括一个关于双性恋的非常受欢迎的TED演讲。这与你整个社会话语的工作有什么联系？这是一个很好的问题，因为我最终写这本书并不是关于过去几十年来我一直在做的LGBT干预研究，而是关于一个完全不同的主题。因此，我一直在做的关于LGBTQ问题的确使我进入了一些困难的对话中。而且我，你知道的，曾促进过围绕宗教和性取向的对话。
I did training for law enforcement on LGBT issues. And all of those things have really helped me to see the benefits of trying to understand where somebody's coming from in addition to or instead of even trying to shift where they are. Because, you know, I've really been able to see how understanding somebody else is so crucial to whatever my goals are in terms of education. somebody or, you know, trying to shift their behavior. So there really is a logical thread there from that previous experience. It kind of pushed you in this direction, it sounds like. I would say so, but even more so in terms of what got me to this book is that I have been teaching, helping skills, and I've also, I was right after the 2016 election teaching
我为执法部门进行了关于LGBT问题的培训。所有这些都真正帮助我看到了试图理解某人来自哪里的好处，除了甚至是为了试图改变他们的立场之外。因为，你知道的，我真的能够看到理解他人对于我无论在教育方面的目标而言是多么关键。某人，或者，你知道的，试图改变他们的行为。因此，从以前的经验来看，确实存在一条逻辑线索。听起来它有点把你推向了这个方向。我想是的，但更确切地说，把我引向这本书的原因是我一直在教授帮助技能，而且我也在2016年大选后不久在教
a class on social justice and counseling psychology where my students were all developing resources to try to help people in the sort of tumultuous times that we were finding ourselves in. And so what came out of that is I started developing some resources too, together with one of my students. And what I ended up with was the thing that I call the flowchart that will resolve all political conflict in our country. So it was really trying to say, you know, is there something, my work is all.
一门关于社会正义和咨询心理学的课程，我的学生们都在开发资源，试图在我们发现自己所处的动荡时期帮助人们。因此，由此产生的结果是，我和我的其中一个学生也开始开发一些资源。我最终得出的成果是我称之为“将解决我国所有政治冲突的流程图”的东西。所以这真的是在试图说，你知道的，是否有某种东西，我的工作全都是
on interventions. I'm not interested only in understanding problems. Like my life's work is really about what do we do about them? How do we actually make things better? And so it turns out that the flow chart did not actually resolve all political conflict in our country. Oh, no. I know. Isn't that remarkable? I totally thought that was going to work. But then I went on to develop the workshop and then the book out of that. So it led down those different paths. And I also just have some experiences myself that have been really transformational in terms of dialogue across political lines. Back in the 90s, I was doing work in pregnancy counseling and ended up bringing together pro-choice and pro-life people to have dialogue with each other. And that was a very meaningful
关于干预措施的。我不仅仅对理解问题感兴趣。就像我毕生的工作实际上是关于我们对它们做些什么？我们如何才能真正让事情变得更好？因此，事实证明，这个流程图实际上并没有解决我国所有的政治冲突。哦，不。我知道。这不是很了不起吗？我完全以为那个会起作用的。但随后我继续开发工作坊，然后由此写成了这本书。所以它沿着那些不同的路径发展下去了。而且我本人也有一些经历，在跨政治阵线的对话方面具有真正的变革意义。早在90年代，我从事过孕期咨询工作，并最终让支持堕胎和反堕胎的人聚集在一起进行对话。那是一次非常有意义的
experience just to understand people from another perspective. So I feel like a lot of what I've done in terms of my research has contributed, but also I'm very engaged in my community. I'm very engaged in the political world. And so in all of those places, I see where these kinds of conversations can really be beneficial. Well, this has been really interesting, Dr. Israel. I appreciate you're joining us today. It's really been a pleasure talking to you, and I hope I have listened actively to what you've said today. I really appreciate your attempts to understand, and I hope I have also understood where you're coming from.
经历，仅仅是为了从另一个视角去理解人们。所以我觉得我在研究方面所做的大部分工作都做出了贡献，而且我也非常积极地参与我的社区。我非常积极地参与政治世界。因此，在所有这些地方，我都看到了这些类型的对话如何真正发挥益处。嗯，这真的很有趣，伊斯雷尔博士。我很感激你今天加入我们。与你交谈真的是一种荣幸，我希望我今天积极倾听了你所说的话。我非常感谢你试图去理解，我也希望我也理解了你的立场。
but this has been really a wonderful opportunity to talk about this work in this book. Well, thank you again. To our listeners, you can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology on our website at speakingof psychology.org or wherever you get your podcasts. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org. That's Speaking of Psychology, all one word, at APA.org. Speaking of Psychology is produced by Lee Wynerman. Our sound editor is Chris Kondyne. Thank you for listening.
但这确实是一个绝佳的机会来谈论这项工作和这本书。嗯，再次谢谢你。对我们的听众，你们可以在我们的网站speakingof psychology.org上找到《心理学畅谈》之前的剧集，或者在你们获取播客的任何地方找到它。如果你对未来的播客有评论或想法，你可以发送电子邮件至speaking of psychology@APA.org。那是Speaking of Psychology，全部连在一起，@APA.org。《心理学畅谈》由李·温纳曼（Lee Wynerman）制作。我们的音频编辑是克里斯·康丁（Chris Kondyne）。谢谢收听。
For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我是金·米尔斯，代表美国心理学会。这一集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。